Продолжение следует...
Это...
Во-первых...
Уже доказанный в литературе...
Способ решения подобных задач...
С точки зрения стратегического...
Планирования разработки месторождения...
Но...
Ключевое...
Это возможность...
Декомпозировать задачи...
И выдавать некоторую интерпретацию...
Тех решений...
Которые мультиагент принимает...
Интерпретация в данном контексте...
Критически важна...
Поскольку мы говорим о системах...
Поддержки принятия решений...
В дальнейшем о системах...
Автоматизированного принятия решений...
И естественно...
Понять то...
Каким образом...
Система пришла к тому или иному действию...
Какое за этим стоит обоснование...
Это ключевое...
Что валидируется к человекам...
И что в конечном счете...
Система должна так или иначе выдавать...
Не только сухое значение NPV...
NPV это у нас чисто дисконтированный доход...
Net present value...
Который используется у нас как...
Универсальная финансовая метрика...
То есть все действия...
Которые происходят на месторождении...
Отражаются на данной экономической метрике...
И скрипт для того...
Чтобы эту экономическую метрику...
С учетом всех переменных считать...
Будет также вам предоставлен...
Так как мы говорим о процессе разработки месторождений...
Как о некой комплексной задаче...
Применительной к искусственному интеллекту...
То суть решения состоит не только в том...
Чтобы составить некую мультиагентную систему...
Где под агентами подразумеваются...
Исключительно языковые модели...
Но и...
Обратить внимание на то...
Что в контексте разработки месторождения...
Существует, например, огромный массив исторических данных...
С какими режимами работали скважины до этого...
До текущего момента...
И к чему это привело?
Для оценки...
Эффективной оценки подобных временных рядов...
Существуют иные модели машинного обучения...
Это могут быть как условные LSTM...
Так и некоторые трансформеры...
Так и некоторые гибридные модели...
Здесь открывается поле для фантазии...
И то, какие, собственно, архитектуры вы примените...
Это есть один из параметров творчества...
Который полностью остается на вашей стороне.
Помимо режимов работы скважин...
Когда мы говорим, в частности, про второй трек...
Где нам необходимо построить суррогатную модель...
Под суррогатной моделью, как правило, понимается та модель искусственного интеллекта...
Которая способна...
Обучившись на конкретном физическом процессе...
В данном случае на гидродинамике отдельно взятого месторождения...
Которое будет входом к задаче...
Предсказывать картину гидродинамики данного месторождения...
Уже с учетом новых вводных переменных...
Новых режимов работы скважин...
И, соответственно, выдавать вам картину гидродинамики...
И показатели дебетов скважин гораздо быстрее...
Чем это может сделать симулятор...
Классическая гидродинамическая модель...
Здесь для того, чтобы построить такую модель...
Такую суррогатную модель...
Можно использовать совершенно любые архитектуры...
От классических сверточных сетей...
До моделей, которые носят названия физически информированных...
И, соответственно, до нейронных операторов...
Которые в большей степени являются архитектурами...
Применимыми в Scientific ML...
В научном и...
Таком отдельном разделе искусственного интеллекта...
И, собственно...
Таким образом построить еще одну модель...
На базе которой может быть создан агент...
Или может быть некий протокол использования данной модели...
Как инструмента...
Здесь все полностью, опять же, является элементом вашего творчества...
И использование всех этих моделей в копии...
Позволит вам построить систему...
Которая будет более оптимальна...
С точки зрения расхода токенов...
И с точки зрения качества того, что она может предсказать...
Сразу могу оговориться здесь...
Что, условно, решение в духе взять LLM-агента...
И сделать его ответственным за одну конкретную скважину...
И размножить вот эту парадигму на все месторождения...
Скорее всего, обречено на провал...
Потому что таким агентам будет очень тяжело...
Как задать протоколы взаимодействия...
Так и в целом прийти к какому-то общему решению...
Не считая то, каким образом будет происходить управление...
Запуска геогидродимической модели...
Для того, чтобы понять...
А как тот или иной агент...
То или иное изменение режима работы скважин...
Повлияло на динамику разработки месторождения...
И это открывает потенциал для еще одного...
Множества методов искусственного интеллекта...
Которые можно применять в рамках такой...
AIOS...
Это методы обучения с подкреплением...
И создания агентов, которые работают...
На одной или нескольких скважинах...
Соответственно, у нас возникают задачи...
Связанные с созданием модели искусственного интеллекта...
Которые в целом в рамках контекста всей задачи...
Могут иметь совершенно разную архитектуру...
Совершенно из разных доменных областей искусственного интеллекта...
И задача построения такого мультиагента...
Где вот агент у нас в широком смысле...
Это и есть задача построения архитектуры...
Где каждый из слоев иерархии подобной операционной системы...
Некоторым образом описан...
Некоторым образом функционирует...
И определены протоколы взаимодействия между уровнями иерархии...
Между уровнями иерархии...
Между конкретными агентами...
В зависимости от того, какую подзадачу...
Каждый из этих уровней решает...
И каким образом организовано...
Взаимодействие агентов...
И дообучение тех моделей, которые за ними стоят...
Дообучение здесь также может быть...
Достаточно важным элементом...
Это больше относится ко второму треку...
Потому что там мы ожидаем архитектуру...
Которая будет иметь возможность...
Большей степени масштабирования, чем на первом треке...
И масштабирование подразумевает...
Что если вы, например, строите суррогатную модель...
Которая обучилась предсказывать гидродинамику...
Для конкретно взятого участка месторождения...
Который вам пришел на вход...
С которым мы работаем в рамках хакатона...
Соответственно, должен быть предусмотрен механизм...
Который эту суррогатную модель как-то оценивает...
И либо сигнализирует о необходимости до обучения...
Либо запускает сам конвейер до обучения...
На основе того, что мультиагент теперь применяется для иного участка месторождения...
И там, соответственно, модель предсказания гидродинамики уже не имеет должной точности.
Цикл функционирования мультиагентной системы состоит в том, что...
Запускается на основе начального состояния месторождения...
Симулятор, который предсказывает гидродинамику и то, каким образом...
Каждая скважина какое количество нефти добывает, какое количество жидкости закачивает...
Производится оценка KPI, оценка экономического показателя...
Производится оценка удовлетворения ограничениям на текущем шаге...
И, собственно, если это прогнозный период некоторый...
То, соответственно, все ограничения должны быть выполнены на протяжении всего прогнозного периода.
Формирование управляющих решений...
То есть на основе той картины, куда мультиагент пришел в данном контексте симуляции...
Мультиагент должен принять решение о том, куда ему двигаться дальше.
Например, если он видит, что дальнейшее увеличение давления в такой-то скважине...
Приводит к критическому росту обводненности где-то в районе соседней скважины...
Соответственно, должно быть принято решение о том, чтобы каким-то образом...
Перебалансировать добычу для того, чтобы в лимиты по ограничению обводненности попасть.
Данные решения, поскольку каждый агент будет отвечать здесь за свою собственную зону ответственности...
Должны быть с помощью протоколов описаны.
Происходит некая оркестрация, согласование решений.
И по итогу этого процесса он в некотором смысле итерационный.
К моменту, когда он сходится, образуется некоторый график, где на каждый момент времени...
Каждая скважина имеет свой режим работы, будь то нагнетательная или добывающая, соответственно...
Свои показатели работы в данном режиме.
И по итогу такого исполнения подобного графика должен быть предоставлено значение NPV, рассчитанное участникам...
Как, собственно, показатель того, каким образом система справилась с поставленной задачей.
В рамках трека номер один, задача, которая будет вам передана, она отличается сравнительно небольшим масштабом с точки зрения количества имеющихся скважин.
Это порядка 40-50 штук.
И, как некий спойлер, месторождение построено таким образом, чтобы ограничить взаимовлияние скважин друг на друга.
То есть это с точки зрения физического моделирования, гидродинамического моделирования.
Это упрощенный случай, который позволит построить архитектуру с некоторыми допущениями.
Собственно, поэтому этот трек стоит дешевле и при этом меньше.
И вы можете здесь, например, обойтись без суррогатной модели, а запускать напрямую GDM, запускать напрямую симулятор.
Здесь подходит как симулятор, который является стандартом у нас в области, это T-навигатор.
Но пугаться его не стоит, несмотря на то, что он лицензированный.
В России есть ряд open-source симуляторов, которые нами провалидированы и имеют точность расхождения по точности от эталона порядка процента,
что позволяет их использовать, ограничений, соответственно, при этом тоже никаких нет.
Такие симуляторы вам будут предоставлены.
Поскольку то решение, которое будет получено участниками, подлежит защите пережюри
и на текущий момент нет особой сложности сгенерировать некий веб-интерфейс,
то требованиями к решению, которые, собственно, будут представлять участники, является не просто мультиагент,
который может функционировать условно как консольное приложение,
а мультиагент с некоторым графическим интерфейсом.
Этот графический интерфейс должен предоставлять возможность запустить,
в общем, использоваться как демонстрация работы,
демонстрировать логику принятия решений,
то есть он должен предоставлять некую интерпретируемость,
некую объяснимость решениям, которые приняты с точки зрения управления фондом скважин.
И в конечном счете весь код того, что, того, что, собственно, будет разработано вами,
должен быть также передан жюри для оценивания.
В рамках защиты финалисты, которые уже пройдут некоторые ранжирования по NPV,
будут приглашены к онлайн-защите,
и в рамках защиты вам как раз нужно будет и демонстрацию провести,
некоторую формат, который мы согласуем попозже,
но в целом идея такая, что даже если вам не хватает времени запустить агента,
мультиагента для сценария и продемонстрировать его эффективность в разумной рамке защиты,
в течение, скажем, там, пары минут,
то можно записать видео того, как именно работает этот мультиагент,
и ужать его по времени, ускорить таким образом,
чтобы вы могли продемонстрировать результат хотя бы в такой динамике.
Модели, которые будут вам выданы в рамках как первого, так и второго трека,
это модели, которые не будут, вернее, содержать в себе ограничений.
Ограничений может быть множество.
Здесь представлены примеры того, какие именно это могут быть ограничения,
это может быть остановка скважин, это может быть ограничения по заказчике,
это может быть некоторый плановый ввод новых скважин в эксплуатацию,
соответственно, мультиагент должен корректно обрабатывать подобные случаи
и сохранять некоторую устойчивость с точки зрения того,
как считается эффект на экономику, как считается экономический показатель.
В рамках предоставленных сценариев не должно быть такого,
чтобы введение некоего сравнительно незначительного ограничения
приводило к тому, что ошибка в NPV относительно референсного сценария,
который будет у нас, как у операторов хакатона, организаторов хакатона,
чтобы эта ошибка превращалась из условных 10% в 1000.
Результат работы мультиагента в том виде, в котором он должен быть предоставлен,
включает в себя файл и значения NPV.
Файл, соответственно, это последовательность воздействий по шагам,
режим эксплуатации скважины, режим закачки,
и ключевое здесь это отсутствие физически невозможных режимов.
Наверное, из базовых примеров здесь можно представить то,
чтобы у вас хотя бы показатели давления с точки зрения физики находились в пределах разумного.
Это то, что вы в том числе можете проверить самостоятельно
и посмотреть, что то решение, которое вы создаете в рамках математической модели,
не нарушает законы физики.
Процедура валидации решений выглядит следующим образом.
В процессе работы над задачей вы создаете некоего мультиагента,
который вы можете дополнительно натренировать на сгенерированных данных ограничений.
Типы ограничений, соответственно, я повторюсь,
будут вам переданы и объяснены организаторам, представителям паутатнефть.
А непосредственные ограничения валидационного сценария
будут предоставлены ближе к окончанию работы над задачей,
ближе к концу выделенных трехнедельное решение.
Соответственно, это включает в себя и начальное состояние геогидродинамической модели,
и набор ограничений, которые до этого, собственно, вы не видели.
Далее происходит формирование решения вашим мультиагентам,
формирование на весь прогнозный период,
который тоже будет являться частью условия.
Важно здесь проверить, что если у нас есть ряд ограничений,
то эти ограничения должны быть учтены обязательно на диапазоне всего прогнозного периода.
Далее вы передаете расписание работы скважин,
режимов работы скважин и заявленное значение NPV,
включая исходный код и документацию организаторам.
На стороне организаторов происходит валидация вашего решения.
Происходит в первую очередь валидация режимов работы скважин,
заявленных вами.
Это, соответственно, может быть произведено без мультиагента как такового,
поскольку расписание режимов работы фактически задает то,
каким образом должно функционировать,
каким образом происходит процесс разработки месторождения.
И этот файл проверяется, и его формат, собственно, должен,
он будет описан представителем PAUT.NEPT,
и этот файл будет являться входным к симулятору,
к навигатору, в частности, он может быть входным.
Далее получается некое значение NPV на стороне организаторов,
и это значение NPV должно совпасть с тем, которое вы заявили.
Естественно, подразумевается некий процент отклонения,
но, опять же, он не должен быть катастрофическим.
То есть если мы видим, что сформированный сценарий радикально отличается от того,
что говорит симулятор, что говорит GDM,
то, соответственно, на этапе финалистов такая команда будет дисквалифицироваться,
и на ее место встанет следующая по значению NPV в рейтинге.
Валидация NPV происходит не только относительно заявленного,
это то, что здесь на слайде у меня, где оценка и сравнение,
но и также относительно референса для того, чтобы, собственно,
в финале, в частности, определить то,
насколько полученные мультиагентные системы,
насколько полученные прототипы iOS
способны превзойти те решения, которые сейчас создаются в рамках организатора
для определения процесса разработки месторождения.
Трек номер два отличается по нескольким пунктам от трека номер один.
И первое ключевое – это, конечно, размер и сложность самой модели месторождения.
Если мы в рамках первого трека говорим о том,
что взаимовлияние скважин крайне ограничено,
что таких скважин у нас от 4 до 5 десятков,
то в рамках второго трека количество скважин уже порядка 100,
и взаимовлияние скважин между собой значительно более ярко выражено.
Это накладывает дополнительные ограничения на архитектуру,
потому что теперь ключевым становится именно построение взаимодействия
различных методов искусственного интеллекта между собой
и то, каким образом выстроена архитектура и иерархия этих слоев.
То есть здесь речь идет не сугубо про мультиагент
и некую аналитику, возможно, временных рядов,
а больше про иерархию слоев, возможности их коммуникации,
протоколы взаимодействия, области ответственности каждого агента,
и в большей степени оцениваться будет это.
И при этом, поскольку при таком масштабе задачи
запуск симулятора может занимать от 30 до 60 минут,
все зависит от того железа, на котором вы будете это считать,
естественно, построить даже достаточно широкий спектр кейсов
для того, чтобы занести их в память или построить облегчающую выборку,
не представляется достаточно оптимальным решением,
и тем более невозможно демонстрировать систему,
которая постоянно запускает симулятор, требующий от получаса времени работы.
Поэтому здесь также возникает потребность создания суррогатной модели.
И это не только вызов с точки зрения создания такой архитектуры,
хотя они и описаны в литературе более или менее,
можно найти что-то уже относительно рабочее
и адаптировать к данным, которые вам будут переданы как входные на трек.
Но и встает вопрос с того, каким образом будет организовано обучение,
то, о чем я сказал в самом начале лекции,
и каким образом будет функционировать агент,
который либо привязан к суррогатной модели,
либо использует ее как инструмент,
как возможность рассчитать последствия принятия решений
в рамках изменения режима работы одной или нескольких скважин.
Скорость решения, соответственно, на втором треке критически важная,
и в рамках иерархии отдельно будет уделено внимание тому,
каким образом суррогатная модель интегрирована в архитектуру EIOS.
Естественно, суррогатная модель не может быть использована 100% времени постоянно,
поскольку она так или иначе будет иметь некоторую погрешность.
Соответственно, в рамках мультиагента ваша задача будет не полностью заменить симулятор
при помощи суррогатной модели, а существенно сократить количество его вызовов.
Это уже даст возможность перейти к тем таймингам,
которые больше характерны для первого трека,
и, соответственно, решить задачу,
уже опираясь на суррогатную модель и механизмы ее взаимодействия и дообучения
на основе данных симулятора.
Таким образом, GDM в рамках второго трека используется только для финальной проверки.
В рамках постановки задачи использование суррогатной модели
в некоторой степени считается опциональным.
То есть мы не будем давить на то, чтобы она была обязательно.
Это, скажем, не влияет на то, будете ли вы допущены к финалу.
Но наличие суррогатной модели будет положительно сказываться
на итоговом рейтинге и на принятии решения о том,
проходите ли вы, в частности, в спорной ситуации, финал или нет.
Точно так же необходимо учитывать ограничения и возмущения
в более широком наборе сценариев, которые соответствуют первому треку.
Точно так же, как в первом треке, необходимо будет генерировать файл
управляющих последовательностей, управляющих режимов работы скважин
для управления фондом скважин и предоставлять значение NPV.
И точно так же необходимо будет создать графический интерфейс,
который позволит вам продемонстрировать данную систему,
то, что вы разработали, и показать жюри, насколько качественно
ваш мультиагент справляется с предоставленными сценариями
и с предоставленными ограничениями.
Собственно, подводя некий итог сравнения треков,
здесь вот такая маленькая табличка, где есть некие тезисы касательно
ключевых отличий.
Это и размер модели.
От 46 до примерно 100 скважин мы прыгаем при переходе с трек 1 в трек 2.
Суррогатная модель, которая в целом, кстати, если вы найдете возможность
ее создать для первого трека, это, безусловно, будет плюсом и на первом треке,
поскольку ключевая идея здесь именно в том, чтобы посмотреть,
каким образом и какие именно протоколы, алгоритмы и обвязки агентов
эффективны в контексте компоновки множества разнородных моделей
искусственного интеллекта в контексте решения общей задачи создания
и центричной операционной системы.
Но критерии масштабируемости, конечно, в большей степени он будет критичен
для второго трека.
То есть он, опять же, и для первого может дать вам возможность
получить дополнительные баллы при оценивании.
Это не останется без внимания.
Но для второго трека, когда мы говорим про более комплексную задачу
и когда у нас есть дополнительные ограничения на суррогатную модель,
как на элемент, который может быть эффективен только в рамках
одного входного датасета и тяжело дообучаем или переобучаем на новые данные,
когда мы пытаемся применить такого мультиагента к и новому участку месторождения.
В этом случае, естественно, для второго трека критерий масштабируемости
говорит о том, каким образом система адаптируется к новым данным
и как она может оценить то, что месторождение, с которым сейчас работает суррогатная модель,
радикально отличается от тех данных, на которых она была обучена
и что это переобучение, дообучение вернее требуется.
Для решения вам таким образом понадобится реализовать некую иерархическую систему,
состоящую из агентов в широком смысле.
Агенты здесь – это как мультимодальные модели, так и модели, построенные на базе классических технологий
глубокого обучения, так и агентами могут выступать агенты в контексте обучения с подкреплением.
Когда мы говорим, например, про управление кустом скважин, такие работы тоже есть,
и, соответственно, в контексте таких задач наиболее эффективными показывают себя именно агенты обучения с подкреплением.
Но так как вам необходимо иметь в рамках архитектуры еще и слой интерпретируемости,
очень важно понимать, каким образом эти агенты будут участвовать в решении задачи
и объясненности конечного результата.
С точки зрения функциональности решение должно принимать входные данные в установленном формате.
С точки зрения визуализации и графического интерфейса
это не должен быть набор исключительно некоторых элементов интерфейса,
условные кнопочки или неиспадающие списки,
и в итоге кнопочка, которая позволяет скачать расписание режимов работы скважин.
Это должна быть визуализация, в идеальном случае визуализация каждого шага изменения режимов работы скважин,
визуализация месторождения и некая интерактивная сцена,
в ходе которой на месторождении расположены скважины,
и вы можете некоторым образом с этими скважинами функционировать,
взаимодействовать, смотреть их параметры, смотреть их режимы.
Это некая картина идеального графического интерфейса,
который даст вам с точки зрения оценки качества решения максимум баллов при оценке жюри.
Программная реализация.
Мы не ограничиваем вас в средствах, которые вы можете использовать.
Здесь замечательная фраза «любые языки программирования и библиотеки»,
но в контексте того, что я уже озвучил,
это больше звучит, как вы можете купить Ford Model T любого цвета,
если только это черный.
То есть, естественно, если вы собираетесь за короткий срок разработать что-то на основе искусственного интеллекта,
то, скорее всего, речь пойдет про Python.
Для того, чтобы решение ваше было переносимым,
крайне рекомендуется докер-контейнеризация среды,
и, естественно, все решения, которые вы будете создавать,
создавать должны быть в репозитории.
Репозитории, собственно, возможно, мы поможем вам создать
и таким образом эту проблему как-то облегчить.
То есть у каждой команды так или иначе будет свой GitHub,
в ходе которого будет вестись работа,
и который поможет вам демонстрировать код.
И с точки зрения процедуры введения хакатона
у нас будет ряд контрольных точек,
насколько я помню, их три.
Где трекеры помогут ответить на ваши вопросы,
помогут оценить, насколько правильно вы двигаетесь,
можно будет показать промежуточные результаты,
позадавать вопросы по архитектуре,
и в каких-то ограниченных условиях
мы не можем за вас решать эту задачу,
но мы можем каким-то образом вас консультировать,
чтобы вы быстрее двигались к конечной задаче,
к конечным решениям.
Пункт 5 здесь отдельно я отмечу еще раз,
я про него уже говорил, по большому счету.
Это возможность валидировать каждый шаг решения,
валидировать ограничения, которые должны быть на каждом шаге решения,
собственно, выполнены.
ограничения включают в себя как входные ограничения,
которые поступают вместе с задачей,
которые являются ограничениями, скажем, на обводненность,
на давление,
и в частности это могут быть также...
Давайте оставим пока так, как есть. Хорошо.
Да, ну и физические ограничения, безусловно.
И выходные файлы,
те, которые вы, собственно, выдаете
как результат решения работы мультиагента,
должны быть обязательно провалидированы.
Там не должны быть некорректные записи,
некорректные числа.
Это, естественно, свидетельствует о некотором баге в программе.
Они имеют место быть периодически, как мы знаем.
Наличие бага...
Наличие багов мы будем стараться вместе с вами
отслеживать в рамках контрольных точек,
так чтобы в процессе финальной валидации,
при условии, что у вас достаточно качественная архитектура
и вы движетесь в правильном направлении,
у вас, соответственно, не возникло
неких похожих казусов,
которые сыграли бы вам существенный минус при демонстрации.
Процедура оценки и критерии оценивания.
Первый блок из этой процедуры я уже озвучил сегодня.
Собственно, это запуск на тестовом кейсе
проверка корректности результата корректности посчитанного NPV.
Ранжируются команды по полученному значению
экономического эффекта по NPV.
В финал проходит 20% команд от числа допущенных к валидации,
соответственно, не более 10 команд на каждый трек.
И финальная проверка и защита – это, собственно, процедура,
в ходе которых дополнительно перезапускается расчет
на предоставленных управляющих последовательностях.
NPV, полученный организаторами, должен совпадать с тем,
который заявлен командой.
И команды, которые проходят в финал,
они допускаются к онлайн-защите.
Онлайн-защита должна выглядеть таким образом,
что у вас всего 7 минут на презентацию по архитектуре,
то есть вы рассказываете, что вы сделали,
как именно и из чего состоит ваше AIOS,
ваше мультиагентное приложение.
Демонстрируйте вашу работу в рантайме,
либо показываете видеодемонстрации.
Это мы отдельно сможем проговорить в рамках контрольных точек.
Чем ближе к решению вы будете подходить,
тем, собственно, понятнее будет,
какие ограничения по производительности возникают
в том или ином случае при той или иной архитектуре.
И по итогу презентации, по итогу демо,
жюри задает вам ряд вопросов коротких,
сравнительно в течение 5 минут, я думаю, не более.
Жюри оценивать будет как архитектуру,
так и методы реализации,
и в целом логику принятия решений.
Но жюри, особенно со стороны организатора,
заинтересовано больше в том,
каким образом можно подобные решения масштабировать,
и выделять будет именно те решения,
которые продуманы с точки зрения не только того,
как они демонстрируют качество работы
на конкретных предоставленных кейсах,
и как хорошо вы их решили,
но и с точки зрения того,
как эти решения выглядят,
как они могут быть интегрированы в дальнейшем,
каким-то образом развитые,
и, соответственно, на базе вот этих оценок
будет выставляться и определяться финальные тройки команд,
которые по каждому треку будут награждены призами.
Формат передачи решений и воспроизводимость,
полный исходный код, опять же, в гид-репозитории.
Там же вы можете положить докер-файл для того,
чтобы, собственно, образ можно было собрать и запустить.
Код, особенно для финалистов, естественно,
нужно будет документировать.
Инструкция по запуску должна обязательно быть
хотя бы в условиях некоторого файла readme,
который позволяет организаторам запустить ваш код,
перепроверить его качество,
посмотреть, насколько хорошо он работает.
и также в рамках репозитория вы предоставляете
наиболее простым способом,
соответственно, это предоставить в рамках репозитория,
расписание режимов работы скважин
и полученное значение NPV.
Форматы этих файлов будут, соответственно,
оговорены в рамках лекции с представителем
паута от нефти.
Суммарно наша лекция подходит к концу.
По трекам то, что необходимо предоставить и создать,
это мультиагенная система управления,
то, что является некой реализацией
и центричной операционной системы.
Файл с режимами работы скважин
на заданный прогнозный период,
расчетное значение NPV,
экономического показателя,
по итогу разработки месторождения
в данном прогнозном периоде,
соответственно, то решение, которое получено
вашим мультиагентом.
Код мультиагента вместе с графическим интерфейсом,
документация, инструкции по развертыванию
и демонстрация работы системы к защите,
так же, как и презентация,
это то, что будет требоваться уже пеналистам, соответственно.
Дополнительно для трека 2
больше требований к масштабируемости
и к архитектуре,
поскольку у вас возникает задача создания
суррогатной модели
на базе тех архитектур,
которые вы, собственно, можете предложить,
которые вы видите наиболее эффективными ограничениями
по архитектурам здесь нет.
Помните, что без полного пакета материалов,
без исходного кода, например,
ваша работа к валидации допущено быть не может.
Мы будем стараться следить за тем,
чтобы никакие такие тонкости
не повлияли на оценку ваших решений
и будем напоминать о том,
что тем, кто чем ближе к финалу оказывается,
тем, собственно, внимательнее к этому относились,
перепроверять те артефакты,
которые вы прилагаете в репозитории,
и постараемся с нашей стороны сделать все возможное,
чтобы критерием участия и награждения
на нашем хакатоне
послужило исключительно качество ваших работ.
На этом я хочу пожелать удачи всем командам,
поздравить с открытием нашего хакатона
и надеюсь увидеть массу прекрасных технических решений,
которые мы постараемся в рамках оговоренных условий вознаградить.
Большое спасибо за внимание.
Продолжение следует...